[Applause]
[Music]
take a look at the t-shirt you're
wearing or your jeans
or even the money you have in your
pocket i'm scottish so i don't have any
to show you unfortunately but
all those things are made of cotton yeah
the dollars and euro bills too well
i have some bad news to tell you one in
five of you may be wearing a product
made by slave labor
right now
this unfortunately is pure mathematics a
quarter of all the cotton in the world
is produced in china
within china 88 of the cotton crops are
grown in the yin zhang region and if
you're a regular follower of
visualpolitik
you'll be aware of what is happening
right now in yin zhang discrimination
against the yeager people
re-education camps and forced labor okay
back to the myth if a quarter of the
world's cotton is produced in china and
of this cotton 88
comes from yin zhang we only have to
make the rule of three to find out what
percentage of cotton is produced in this
region where the uyghur minority
is practically enslaved by the chinese
government
you don't even have to get out your
calculator because i'm going to tell you
it's
22 yeah that's right 22 or just over a
fifth of all the world's cotton that we
all like
so much is the product of forced labor
and it's used by big brands like h
m adidas ikea and nike and in case
anyone thinks it's not a big deal
brace yourselves because this is not the
worst thing china is not the only
country that is covering up human rights
abuses in cotton production
and although it may be hard to believe
there is something even worse
than forced labour check this out
the nimble fingers myth is particularly
relevant to cottonseed production where
employers claim that tasks of
cross-pollination
emasculation and hand pollination are
best undertaken by pre-pubescent female
children
as is the case in india ilo
international labor
organization yeah that's right in the
21st century there are still producers
who publicly argue the benefits
of child labour and let's be clear we
are not talking about teenagers but
about children who start work from the
age
of five
they are also very often employed to
pick cotton because compared to adult
pickers they have
two advantages one is that because
children are shorter they don't have to
bend down to pick up the cotton
and two is that they can be paid much
much less
than any adult so if you are an
unscrupulous business person with no
government control
the best thing you can do in your cotton
field is to enslave
i don't know an entire school and i was
saying that as a joke but there are
countries that do
exactly that when the fall comes they
take students out of the classroom
to go and pick
and you're probably thinking so in this
video we're going to talk about terrible
things right like modern slavery and
child labor because if we are grant i
need to go make myself a cup of tea
if this is going to be one of those ones
but the truth is that we are not because
in the midst of this very bleak
situation
we actually have some good news
[Music]
forced and child labor in uzbek cotton
fields continues to fall
ilo so now you will see so what's the
point if you remember in a visual
politics video in which we talked about
uzbekistan
we said the country was run by a wild
abject dictatorship and that it had
no scruples about enslaving its
population to pick cotton
and in case anyone was wondering the
same dictator who ruled then is ruling
now
we are talking about mr chavkat mir
zoyoyev and i may have gotten that name
wrong but
he's a dictator so who cares
in that respect nothing has changed the
uzbeks continue to suffer under a regime
that considers human rights to be
at best optional and you might ask then
how is it possible that
all of a sudden this dictator has had an
attack of conscience and he's going to
end both forced and child labor has he
been visited
like scrooge by three dickensian ghosts
and realized that he has to change his
ways
well not exactly so why has uzbekistan
decided to eliminate forced and child
labour how is it doing it and to what
extent can it serve as a model for other
cotton producing countries today
we're going to answer all these
questions and before we take a look at
some history i just want to tell you
about our new channel
visual academy from the coast the
spaniards penetrated and began
it's covering all the most interesting
people places and periods in history
with some great animation
and i can only assume a very handsome
sounding voiceover gag and that man's
name was
genghis khan you should check it out and
now
let's get cracking
[Music]
it's everywhere it may surprise you but
cotton is one of the 10 most widely
planted crops in the world
behind wheat corn rice soy beans and
some cereals around 2.6
of all cultivated land on the planet is
planted in cotton that's about the same
surface area as germany
or poland
furthermore as you know unlike wheat or
corn cotton is not eaten but even so it
occupies twice as much land as
for example potato fields what's more up
to 300 million people
or almost three percent of the world's
population work at some stage of the
cotton production chain and you're
probably thinking
but why do we need to plant so much
cotton if in principle it's only used
for clothing and
not all clothes because there are also
clothes that are made of linen or hemp
or a myriad of other fabrics then that
might be true but it turns out that
cotton is used for
pretty much everything in life
take a look this five euro bill is
actually pure cotton
think about it if the bills were made of
paper it would be impossible for them to
last very long to withstand getting damp
not to mention
the occasional spin in the washing
machine on the other hand if they are
made with cotton fiber they are more
robust
flexible and resistant but that's not
all
cotton is also used in a multitude of
objects that we use in our daily lives
home textiles coffee filters shoelaces
and
it's even a component of some flat
screen tvs
[Music]
from cotton seeds and oil is extracted
that is used in the production of soaps
margarine and some plastics cotton is
even used in
spacesuits and here's a fun fact in 2019
trainer tried to plant cotton on the far
side of the moon
given the importance of cotton in our
lives it is easier to understand why
there are so many countries that grow
cotton there are at least 90 of them
practically half of the world the main
producers are
india china and the united states and
uncle sam exports the most cotton to the
rest of the world
for its part the european union is
pretty far behind the only cotton grown
here is in spain
and greece and production does not come
close to that of other continents
but today we are going to focus on a
different region one where cotton is so
important that
in relative terms they are one of the
largest producers of this
white gold per square kilometer and pear
inhabitant we are talking about
countries that are so dependent on
cotton cultivation that they've even
drawn the plant on their national coat
of arms
and they also have quite favorable
climatic conditions for producing white
gold
we're talking about central asia or as
we know it uzbekistan turkmenistan
tajikistan
kyrgyzstan kazakhstan pakistan and
afghanistan
you know the stands
[Music]
cotton has a very curious property
because it is a plant that does not
tolerate frost it needs a warm climate
but without exceeding 35 degrees celsius
in addition the ideal environment is one
where there is little moisture because
during the process of harvesting the
cotton
it has to be dry but at the same time
the plant itself
needs a lot of water for example to
plant 200 grams of cotton which is what
is used to make
let's say this t-shirt 2 000 liters of
water are needed of all the water used
in agricultural work
3.5 goes exclusively to the production
of cotton
[Music]
so now if you look on a map for a place
that is warm but not too hot
without frost with a moderately dry
climate but it still has a lot of water
the truth is that you will find that
there are quite a few areas
with optimal conditions for growing
cotton these days
73 of the world's cotton is produced
thanks to irrigation systems and that
means
if you grow a lot of cotton you use up a
lot and i mean
a lot of water so much that there are
regions that are losing their rivers and
lakes because of the massive production
of white gold remember this because in a
few minutes i'm going to tell you about
the biggest water tragedy
ever caused by cotton
having said that we are not only talking
about ecological disasters
but also humanitarian ones because there
are countries where cotton is harvested
by slave labor
or even children
and what's worse it is very difficult to
know if the t-shirt you are wearing
right now
is one of the garments made by forced
labor because the cotton supply chain is
one of the most complex in the world
i mean this one could be made by slave
labour
so now i'm going to tell you the story
of a dirty slave labor made cotton
t-shirt like
i've never worn first a seed is planted
in one of those fields we talked about
warm dry and with a lot of water a few
months later someone has to pick off the
typical cotton balls and take them to a
ginning factory where the lint is
separated from the seat
and any kind of impurities the cotton
lint which is used in the textile
industry travels to another place where
it is washed and passed through a press
to become
a block of cotton which is also called
weirdly
a cake this goes to the next stage of
production where is transformed into a
yarn
then comes the weaving or knit process
in which this yarn becomes a fabric and
finally someone will make our t-shirt
which can then go on display in one of
the windows of the major fashion brands
now everything i have told you could
happen in one country but the truth is
that this is not often the case the most
common story is that the cotton is
picked in country a transformed into a
fabric in country b
made up in country c and finally sold
in country d we are talking about a
super traditional sector with a very
long production chain and a lot of hands
through which the cotton weaves its way
before becoming
a t-shirt
therefore at the end of the day it is
very difficult to know who produces the
raw cotton
used to make for example zara's t-shirts
and
i know what you're wondering right now
if cotton is in such high demand
why isn't it picked by machines it may
surprise you but agriculture is one of
the sectors that has changed the most in
the last century nowadays
almost nobody harvests wheat by hand
harvesting machines
they do it so why in the case of cotton
are children
still being used well let's take a look
at that
right now
[Music]
the soviet trap normally when we talk
about the great empires of the world
we think of the british the french the
spanish colonisers
maybe even the americans but not the
russian empire because most of us take
it for granted that the russian empire
is so big because well
russia is kind of big it's as simple as
that right i think maybe when the
countries of the world were dividing up
all the lands of the planet russia said
give me two but instead drew the joker
but the truth is
no in fact the great russian empire
expanded very slowly
and only became great as such in the
18th century when they took over all of
siberia they continued to expand in the
south until they reached central asia
and that's where
they found the perfect place to plant
cotton
a warm dry climate with several rivers
to boot so what's the
problem the problem was that for some
reason they didn't trust the entire
population they had just
forcibly annexed you know colonizer
stuff besides like all good colonisers
they thought they were a superior race
and that's why all the production was
always in the hands
of russian businessmen now we jump ahead
to october
1917. what happened on this date exactly
goodbye russian empire hello union of
soviet socialist republics
at that point the communist party said
now we are all a brotherhood we are all
comrades today for you tomorrow for me
so central asian republics keep planting
cotton as if there were no tomorrow and
in return the rest of the ussr will see
to it that you lack
nothing and that helps to explain why
uzbekistan produced two-thirds of all
the cotton in the soviet union
[Music]
so you're probably thinking now well
that's good right i mean
what's wrong with uzbekistan producing a
lot of cotton well believe me
it is a problem you remember that
growing cotton requires a lot of water
right
and i mean a lot of water well
uzbekistan is a desert country so where
did they get all the water the answer
is in the aral sea if i ask you to point
it out on a map you would better be
pretty quick
because it has practically disappeared
that's right the rlc is one of the
largest lakes in the world
or rather we should say it was
check this out
we are talking about one of the largest
salt lakes in the world on the border
between uzbekistan and kazakhstan which
in turn
was fed by several rivers well what the
communist party did was to say let's see
here we have the fourth largest lake in
the world with a lot of aquatic life and
totally dependent on two rivers we can
divert the water from these rivers to
the cotton plantations
and see what happens as you can imagine
when the two rivers stopped filling the
aryl sea
it began to gradually shrink and at the
same time keep in mind that as the
soviet union was the communist country
par
excellence all production including
cotton plantations was in the hands of
the state
what does this mean well those who
worked in these fields did not own the
land they did not keep the cotton they
picked and they had to meet
very high delivery quotas for cotton but
on the other hand the field was not
their property and they could stop
managing it at any point that the
committee on duty told them to in
conclusion
they had no incentive to invest in
machinery and i know what you're going
to tell me now it's been almost 30 years
since the fall of the soviet union in
fact uzbekistan
is no longer a soviet republic but its
own independent country and yes
you are right but as far as ownership of
the countryside is concerned the system
remains virtually
intact and now i know what you are
thinking in the 1990s both uzbekistan
and tajikistan became independent
and yes you're right but their economies
were designed to export a single product
cotton
think about it if depending on oil is
problematic a commodity which has much
more demand and fewer producers imagine
what happens if your nation is dependent
on cotton from one day to the next
uzbekistan was competing
face to face with the united states and
china they had
no technology and no industry that
produced anything else
no matter that the countries of central
asia became independent from the soviet
union
land ownership remained in the hands of
the state
listen up
the land its minerals waters flora and
fauna
other natural resources shall constitute
the national wealth and shall be
rationally used and protected by the
state article 55
constitution of uzbekistan
land its entrails water airspace flora
and fauna and other natural resources
shall be owned by the state and the
state guarantee their effective use
in the interests of the people article
13 constitution of tajikistan that's
right
in these countries the very earth itself
belongs to the state
that means that you may be lucky enough
to be given a farm but in return
you will have to plan what the state
tells you so
once again it doesn't pay for farmers to
make large investments in machinery but
that's not the only reason that
harvesting isn't mechanized even if it's
less efficient hand-picked cotton pays
much better because it's better quality
just to give you an idea a kilo of
hand-picked cotton pays 16 cents more
than machine-picked cotton in other
words
both the united states and europe
machine harvest cotton and can therefore
offer more competitive prices than
uzbekistan and the other central asian
countries
the only way these countries can compete
is in the niche market of hand-picked
cotton mostly because there are very few
producers of this type if we also keep
in mind that these producers tend to be
wild dictatorships we find ourselves
with barbarities
like this
uzbekistan has second highest prevalence
of modern slavery
in the world euro asian net every year
up to two
million people worked on uzbek cotton
plantations against their will
and that included children basically
september came and instead of getting
out their new textbooks
students and their teachers would take a
bus go to a cotton plantation
and get a one
it may seem incredible to you but this
has been the reality in uzbekistan until
just a couple of years ago
when this came out in the international
media the uzbek government tried to
backpedal a little bit and banned child
labour's in the cotton fields but
they didn't do it quite right although
the children stopped working on the
plantations
their teachers still spent september
october
and november picking cotton so what's
the outcome whose back children
couldn't go to school so now the burning
question is
so what has happened more recently to
change this situation why has uzbekistan
banned slavery almost overnight well
that is what we're going to look at
right now
the market decides mate look at the
label on your possibly dirty slave made
t-shirt you degenerate i would never
wear such a thing i'm sure it doesn't
say
made in uzbekistan it probably says
something like made in turkey or made in
bangladesh and you'll say
what why are they lying to us as is
always the case the answer is complex
do you remember the cotton production
chain we talked about before which is
one of the longest and most complex in
the world
and what if i told you that the country
that imports the most cotton from
countries like turkmenistan tajikistan
and uzbekistan
is turkey
and in turn turkey is one of those
countries where companies like nike or h
m have their textile factories now it
should begin to make sense
indeed turkey is one of the largest
cotton hubs in europe
it receives the raw material from
central asia and converts it into
clothing
or sends fabric to large textile
factories in other countries
it is almost impossible to trace where
the cotton in your t-shirt comes from
however
i'm sure none of you would buy a t-shirt
knowing that slave labor has been
involved
i certainly wouldn't of course there's
already a huge debate around companies
outsourcing to countries with cheap
labor but no one
absolutely no one defends the use of
slavery and some will think the
multinationals don't care about
enslaving anyone if it means making
money and though sometimes that's true
consumers
don't think the same way and neither do
ngos
nor most importantly the courts so
what is the solution well on the one
hand quality seals right now there are a
lot of agencies that oversee cotton
production and only put the seal on
finished items if no children
or slaves have been involved in
production and that explains news
like this
[Music]
uzbekistan over 100 companies ashu uzbek
cotton euro asian net indeed
this is what happened in 2012. suddenly
uzbekistan
lost almost all of its buyers we're not
just talking about companies here we're
talking
about governments
eu lawmakers block textile deal with
uzbekistan over child labor concerns
rferl so suddenly uzbekistan became
the golem of countries small despised
and obsessed with its precious
cotton but not only that uzbekistan
needed to reduce its dependence on
cotton for example
they needed to start growing wheat so
they wouldn't have to import it on the
other hand if they wanted to continue
selling cotton they had no choice
but to leave slavery behind and that
explains why
since 2012 the country has been
reforming its policies
first they stopped forcing children to
grow and pick cotton
then they stopped enslaving officials
and we're not just talking
about a superficial change here
according to the international labour
organization which is not exactly
friendly to the uzbek government
94 of the people who were picking cotton
in 2019
did so voluntarily of course that still
means there is six percent of slave
labor
but remember that we are talking about
changing a system that has sustained the
entire national economy
for decades and now i know what you're
thinking about what we were thinking
about what you thought before
uzbekistan has no technology and now
they have no slaves how can they be
competitive in the marketplace
the answer lies in the root of the
problem why are there no tractors
in uzbekistan exactly because there is
no private initiative
so it's time to change the rules of the
game
pakistan to start land privatization
next year
as china faces u.s forced labor
sanctions uzbekistan becomes a model
forbes and now i know what you're
thinking about what you were thinking
about what you thought before what you
thought before
come on grant is a dictatorship as
corrupt as the uzbek one really going to
sell off their fields transparently and
on that one you are absolutely right the
privatization of uzbek cotton is
anything but squeaky clean and also the
laws are pretty
confusing so what they've actually done
has been to seed the cultivation of the
cotton fields and then the processing of
it to private entrepreneurs
one for each region in other words each
of these entrepreneurs has a monopoly on
cotton
in their region and without a doubt the
greatest beneficiary of all this
privatization is a local company
called uztex we are talking about the
largest conglomerate in uzbekistan and
one that has very clear connections
with the government this company has
taken over crops from most
of the regions but to be honest
corruption is nothing the pure uzbeks
don't already know about now at least
they are starting to see
farm machinery in their fields listen up
uzbekistan to speed up mechanization of
cotton picking who's daily
but wait just one moment if you thought
that privatizing the countryside was
enough to end slavery once and for all
you are very much mistaken
many of these factories are having
trouble finding labor so think about
this
before it was as simple as forcing
everyone to pick cotton now they have to
get used to making
work contracts and in many cases some of
these private farms are turning to local
authorities to get people
back to work remember that we are still
talking about a dictatorship where there
is
no rule of law even today many local
politicians can use the police
to enslave the population
on the other hand independent contracted
workers do not have
enviable conditions either at the moment
the going rate for a cotton picker is
about
two and a half euros a day this is a low
wage
even by uzbek standards however the
uzbekistan of 2020 is much fairer than
that of 2012. more importantly all of
these new landowners are starting to
invest in cotton pressing technology
today
70 of the country side of uzbekistan is
already in private hands and is starting
to use agricultural machinery
but not only that all these new
landowners especially those belonging to
the uztex group are starting to invest
in cotton processing factories in other
words in a few years uzbekistan could
stop exporting raw cotton and start
selling higher value added products such
as cotton yarn
or even clothing do you think that the
uzbek reforms are a good example for
other cotton producing countries do you
think that international sanctions could
be more effective now against slave
labor in xinjiang
and do you think that i was ever wearing
a t-shirt because you were mistaken i
was always just this
silk shirt leave your answer in the
comments as always we really hope you
enjoyed this video please hit like if
you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos
every week don't forget to check out our
friends also at the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not my dusted tones
also this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage
and as always i'll see you next time and
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media we have a
podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there